hi everyone today I'm going to tell you
about the dynamic mode decomposition or
DMD which is an emerging data driven
technique to obtain linear reduced order
models for high dimensional complex
systems and in addition to linear
reduced order models we also can extract
from from this data spatial temporal
coherent structures or patterns that
dominate the observed measurement data
from that dynamical system okay so I'm
going to walk you through the overview
of DMD and then in later videos we're
gonna see how to actually code it up and
apply it to various systems and we're
also going to look at modern innovations
and extensions to the theory okay so
dynamic mode decomposition DMD
essentially gives you a coupled system
of spatial temporal modes
okay this was originally introduced in
the fluid dynamics community by Peter
Schmidt and it was later connected to
this nonlinear dynamical Systems Theory
called Koopmans Koopman theory by Clancy
Rowley
egor message and their collaborators
okay so this came out of the fluids
community so I'm going to start by
showing you this kind of fluids example
but since then DMD has been applied to a
broad range of systems including disease
modeling neuroscience robotics finance
plasmas you name it DMD can be applied
and part of the reason it's so
applicable is because it's purely a data
driven method it doesn't require any
knowledge of the underlying equations of
motion it can work anytime you have data
you can essentially feed that data into
DMD kind of turn the crank and you get
out these spatial temporal modes and a
linear dynamical system for how they
evolve in time okay so what we're going
to think about is in this case how this
is a data driven method and I should
point out that this can also be directly
applicable to experimental fluids so if
I have PIV images from an experiment I
can use those with DMD as well but for
what I'm going to show you I'm
essentially going to walk you through
DMD on this example of simulated fluid
flow
passed cylinder so this is the vortex
shedding movie of flow past a cylinder
and what DMD first does is it takes all
of this collected data so if I had a
movie of my flow of all thing in time I
would essentially break that movie up
into snapshots or images as they evolve
in time so my flow state at time one my
flow state at time two and so on in this
case I'm plotting vorticity and at each
time step I have something like a
hundred thousand measurements of
vorticity in space then what I do is I
organize this data into these big
matrices X and X prime okay so the
columns of X the X matrix are
essentially the columns of my data
reshaped into sorry my snapshots of data
reshaped into very very tall column
vectors that are evolving in time so x1
is a big column vector where I take my
my flow field at time one and I reach a
pit into a tall column vector X 2 is the
next snapshot X 3 is the next snapshot
and so on and so forth
so the columns are essentially evolving
in time along with the dynamics of this
system in this case these are the
nonlinear Navy or Stokes equations and
so I'm collecting data from either a
simulation or an experiment and I'm
stacking I'm reshaping those those flow
field snapshots into very tall vectors
evolving in time so that's what X is
okay X prime is that exact same data
matrix but advanced one time step into
the future okay so instead of X at time
one at time two at time three X prime is
shifted 1 delta T in the future so it's
X at time 2 X at time 3 X at time 4 and
so on and so forth ok and so essentially
the first step of DMD is to collect your
data then what you do is you organize it
into these big matrices and for fluids
data these matrices are usually very
tall and skinny okay so maybe I have you
know hundreds of thousands or even
millions or billions of measurements per
time snapshots but maybe I only have a
few hundred or a thousand snapshots in
time
okay usually that's how how these kind
of fluid data evolved is that I have a
ton of spatial measurements may be
millions of spatial measurements but I
only have a few hundred snapshots in a
time so these are super tall skinny
matrices and then what the dynamic mode
decomposition does is it essentially
tries to find a best fit linear operator
a that advances X into X prime okay so
the basic assumption here is that you
can write down this dynamical system in
terms of a linear dynamical system so
we're gonna say X prime is approximately
equal to some big a matrix times X okay
that's the framing of Peter Schmidt's
paper is basically try to find the best
fit linear operator a that best agrees
with this data the best maps X into X
prime now I told you that we're doing
this on really really high dimensional
data where maybe I have you know a
million degrees of freedom a million
spatial measurements in my column vector
then this a matrix is a million by
million matrix okay so it has a trillion
elements you definitely don't want to
actually compute this a matrix let alone
look at things like its eigenvalues and
eigenvectors okay so what the DMD
actually does is it approximates the
leading eigen decomposition of the
leading eigenvalues and eigenvectors of
this a matrix without ever actually
computing the a matrix okay so that's
kind of the the special sauce or the
what's under the hood of the DMD
algorithm is trying to approximate the
dominant eigenvalues and eigenvectors of
this a matrix this best fit linear
operator without ever actually computing
a in the first place because it's way
too big to store and compute and work
with okay but you know I'll tell you
about how you do that in a minute but
once you get those leading eigen values
and eigen vectors of a essentially you
can interpret any eigenvector of a has
the shape of one of these column vectors
and that i ghen vector of a can be
reshaped into a flow field so these are
kind of eigen flow fields that are these
dominant spatial
parent modes and the nice thing is
because their eigenvalues they
correspond to a coherent time dynamics
either pure tone sine and cosine waves
or pure exponential decay or exponential
growth or combinations kind of growing
or decaying sines and cosines so getting
the leading dominant eigen decomposition
of this a matrix gives you these spatial
temporal coherent modes these these
dominant coherent structures and it also
gives you the I gain values the time
dynamics of how these modes evolve in
time and so if I had kind of this
leading eigen decomposition of a I could
use that to predict how my system will
evolve in the future by essentially
predicting those future dynamics and
recombining these modes to figure out
what my state will do in the future okay
so DM D is extremely useful it can be
used for Diagnostics you can just use
these modes to understand more about the
physics and the flow structures and kind
of what's driving your system of
interest you can also use DMD to get an
actual model this kind of the
eigenvalues of a give you a model for
how these these modes evolve in time and
eventually we're gonna see that you can
use these linear models for things like
control okay so that's kind of where
we're going okay good now here's the
actual guts of what goes on under the
hood to compute DMD because remember I
don't want to compute that gigantic you
know million by million a matrix so
instead what I do in most fluid systems
and in most high dimensional complex
dynamical systems of interest disease
modeling neuroscience fluids if you
collect enough snapshots of data in time
what you usually find is that there are
dominant coherent patterns that emerge
okay so even if there's a million
degrees of freedom of your system
in this case of vortex shedding there's
a pre repeatable low dimensional set of
patterns that emerge from those dynamics
so the first step in DMD is essentially
computing a singular value decomposition
of this big data matrix X to find your
dominant coherent structures which
the columns of this you matrix so for
those of you who are familiar with the
proper orthogonal decomposition this is
just the PIO D and these columns of U
are your p OD modes and they're
organized hierarchically from most
important to least important in terms of
capturing the variance of X ok so in
many systems even if I have a million by
thousand matrix I might be able to
approximate it with the first five
columns or first ten columns of this U
matrix so this will be the first five or
ten PID modes ok so then what we do is
instead of writing X prime equals a
times X we substitute in the singular
value decomposition here so it's now a
times the singular value decomposition
of X and I could compute what the big a
is by taking the pseudo inverse so one
of the nice things about singular value
decomposition is it's easy to invert
this v-star because it's nor it's a
unitary matrix so I multiply on the
right by V then I multiply on the right
by Sigma inverse and then I multiply on
the right by you
complex conjugate transpose and I can in
pseudo inverse all of this stuff to
isolate what a is okay but we don't
actually want to compute the million by
million a and so instead what we do is
we project a onto these dominant
singular vectors U star and U and we get
this smaller a tilde so if I had a
thousand snapshots in time this would be
a thousand by thousand matrix instead of
a million by million matrix okay and so
then I can actually isolate this a tilde
directly from the data that I have okay
so I take the SVD of X so I have u Sigma
and V I have X Prime and I compute this
quantity here which is this little a
tilde matrix and the way I think about a
tilde a tilde is a linear best-fit
dynamical system that tells me how my p
OD modes evolve in time how these these
dominant coherent patterns evolve in
time okay and so this is a much much
smaller matrix it's maybe thousand by
thousand one hundred by hundred and it
has the same
use as the big a matrix okay so that's
something you can prove you can actually
go through this formulation and prove
that this little a tilde has the same
eigen values the same nonzero eigen
values as big a and so I can compute the
eigen decomposition of this little
matrix to figure out what my eigen
values of the big matrix are okay so
that's the step here I do a tilde W
equals W lambda so W are my eigen
vectors and lambda are my eigen values
of my reduced dynamic operator a tilde
okay and so now I have the eigen values
but what I really wanted were the eigen
vectors of a I wanted these because
those eigen vectors are these mode
shapes over here those are my dominant
coherent structures and so the last step
to so I have the eigen vectors of my
little projected a matrix and now the
last step is to get these these big
eigenvectors of the original a matrix
using this formula here and this is
actually the formula from Jonathan twos
2014 jcd paper this is slightly
different than the original formulation
that that Peter Schmidt wrote down and
it Jonathan two actually proved that
these high dimensional eigen vectors are
actual eigenvectors of the original a
matrix but basically you can just
compute these you know what all of these
matrices are these are your little
eigenvectors of a tilde these are the
matrices from your singular value
decomposition and this is your big time
shifted data matrix and so you can
compute all of these you can get the
eigen values and the the eigen vectors
of the big a matrix without ever
actually computing the big a matrix
you're only working on this little a
tilde matrix okay so that's actually the
entire d-md algorithm it's really like
four or five lines of code in MATLAB to
do this entire procedure it's super
simple if you have X and X Prime you can
do all of this and it's very very fast
and scalable to get these these
eigenvalues and eigenvectors okay
something else I'll point out that's not
in this simple formulation is this is
the exact SVD so if this was a million
by thousand matrix I would have a
thousand modes here and I would get a
thousand by thousand a mate
a tilde and a thousand eigenvalues and a
thousand eigenvectors but if my system
has really really low dimensional
behavior like I can describe X with the
first five columns of U and capture
let's say 99% of the energy of the
system then I can substitute all of
these by the first five columns of U the
first five by five block of Sigma and
the first five columns of V and then
what I get out is this reduced SVD and I
get a little 5x5 a tilde this is even
more reduced it's just the dynamics on
those first five p OD coefficients and
then I get five DMD eigenvalues in five
DMD modes okay
we call these eigenvectors modes because
they're spacial temporal coherent mode
shapes okay so that's all there is
that's how you actually compute DMD you
essentially this is what DMD is defined
as is essentially the leading
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of that big
a matrix but you compute them without
ever actually resorting to building this
gigantic million by million a matrix
okay and once you have that you can
actually get future state predictions so
now that you have your modes and your
eigen values if you know what your
amplitudes of each of those modes are
this is kind of your initial condition
of how how much each of those modes is
expressed in your data then you can run
this forward in time you can essentially
take these eigenvalues to the higher and
higher powers or e to the lambda T and
predict what your system will do in the
future okay so that actually works
pretty well for periodic systems like
this so if you have a high dimensional
system that has some dominant periodic
or quasi periodic behavior you can
actually get a really good approximation
even if it's strongly non-linear with
this very simple linear DMD now if you
have strong transients or intermittent
phenomena or non stationary behavior
then it gets more complicated and you
have to resort to kind of fancier
regressions and a more general nonlinear
framework okay what I really want to
emphasize though is that all the DMD is
and this is something Jonathan to
pointed out all the DMD is is a best fit
linear model for
measurements X into one time step in the
future X Prime it's a best fit linear
model and so essentially you can use all
of the powerful techniques of regression
to find this DMD model so for example I
could I could do different types of
regression noise robust regression or
sparsity promoting regression to find
other variants of this this a matrix
okay and so that's kind of the big
picture overview of what DMD is it's a
procedure where you take your data you
stack it into matrices and you find the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of a
hypothetical best fit linear operator so
i took this picture from from my wife
bing and this is kind of a cute
representation just pictorially of what
the dmt is so we did this first step of
the singular value decomposition to do a
dimensionality reduction step that's
basically the principal components
that's what the principal components
analysis does is it takes high
dimensional data and minds it for the
fewest the fewest dominant patterns that
explain that data and then DMD is
essentially what you would get if
principal components and the Fourier
transform in time had a baby okay so you
basically build this linear regression
model on principal components or p OD
modes or SVD modes they're all the same
thing you build this linear regression
model a tilde this little model that
tells me how the principal components
evolve and then I diagonalize that
linear model to find what are the
dominant patterns in time what are the
type of frequencies of how linear
combinations of these principal
components evolve in time okay
so DM D is this adorable kind of mashup
of principal components in space and the
Fourier transform in time okay okay one
last thing a shameless plug we did write
a book on this the dynamic mode
decomposition this is a cyan book Nathan
cuts myself being Brunton and Josh
Proctor and so if you're interested in
DMD if you want to know about the
extensions and applications if you want
to go through code you can read all
about it here
and work it out for yourself okay so
basically that's the dynamic mode
decomposition in a nutshell there's a
lot more under the hood there's tons of
extensions of this for what if I didn't
have full state measurements what if I
didn't have measurements that were
resolved in time what if I'm actively
trying to control my system what if I
have noise we'll talk about all of those
and we'll code it up on a few examples
in the upcoming videos okay thank you